welcome to CBS this morning we begin
with this because we've got major new
developments in the house and
Pietschmann inquiry newly released text
messages reveal how much pressure the
Trump administration put on Ukraine to
investigate a company linked to former
Vice President Joe Biden's son former US
special envoy to Ukraine kurt volker who
resigned last week gave congress pages
of text exchanges he answered questions
for more than nine hours yesterday the
Democratic chairman of three House
committees say the testimony reflects
quote serious concerns meanwhile
President Trump not only asked Ukraine
to investigate the Biden's he also
called on China yesterday to do the same
we'll have more on that in a moment but
first aid O'Keefe is on Capitol Hill he
and a team of producers stayed up late
combing through those texts said what
did you find well Anthony good morning
the text messages show administration
officials coaching the Ukrainians on
what to say in order to win a meeting
with President Trump specifically that
they would commit to investigating that
Ukrainian company with ties to hunter
Biden but at least one diplomat on these
text chains raised concerns about
linking that request to releasing
Ukraine's military aid the pages of text
messages Kurt Volker handed over to
Congress show that top US diplomat to
Ukraine at the time bill Taylor
repeatedly raised concerns about the
administration's Ukraine's strategy in a
text last month he wrote I think it's
crazy to withhold security assistance
for help with a political campaign but
Gordon Sunland the US ambassador to the
European Union disagreed saying I
believe you are incorrect about
president Trump's intentions no quid pro
quos of any kind he suggested taking the
conversation offline Taylor is a career
foreign service officer with over 20
years of experience
sunland is a Republican donor who gave
about 1 million dollars to the Trump
campaign before being named to his post
the texts also show Volcker Sandlin and
the president's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani coaching Ukrainian officials on
how they could secure a White House
visit by publicly promising to
investigate a Ukrainian company linked
to hunter Biden an election meddling but
when a White House meeting was never
planned Taylor
concerns again asking are we now saying
that security assistance and White House
meeting are conditioned on
investigations after hours of testimony
both Democrats and Republicans said
Volcker helped their opposing positions
there was no quid pro quo whatsoever
there was an ongoing scheme is the
whistleblower described to quote unquote
play ball now today the House Oversight
Committee is expected to subpoena the
White House for more information on that
July call between the president and the
Ukrainian leader they also want to learn
about any attempts to conceal that call
or to learn about who exactly is the
whistleblower that set this off also
today the watchdog for the intelligence
community will be back up here on
Capitol Hill meeting behind closed doors
with the House Intelligence Committee
Tony
very interesting new details ed thank
you very much